and the Overton Window is so
uncomfortably narrow that I would I
would be long ideas more than any other
point in the last 50 years I think I
think we're not going to find solutions
inside the intellectual straightjacket
in which our universities and our
society put us I would save anything if
I if I had to sort of characterize the
intellectual landscape you know we've
been in a world for a very long time in
which somehow the range of intellectual
debate has gotten more and more narrow
and sort of the Overtoun windows shifted
to the left but generally in an ever
narrower way and you could sort of say
that we've been in a bear market for
ideas I think for something like the
last 50 years and so you know a lot of
the people you cited I think of as pre
the late 1960s and that in the last 50
years if you had crazy ideas it could
ideas that were outside the box those
were always bad and you got clobbered
and you couldn't get tenure you couldn't
even you couldn't get funding because
everything was peer-reviewed up the
wazoo and and and I think we're now at a
point where we've been in such a long
bear market for ideas and the Overton
Window is so uncomfortably narrow that I
would I would be long ideas more than
any other point in the last 50 years I
think I think we're not going to find
solutions inside the intellectual
straightjacket in which our universities
in our society put us and I think I
think there will be positive returns to
ideas greater than there have been in
the last 50 years